With the sequentially consistent memory model, let's
come back to a parallel program. So, a
parallel program is making read write accesses
to shared memory, some of them offer data,
and some of them offer synchronization. Now,
so far as the sequentially consistent memory model
it does not distinguish between accesses coming from
the processors as data accesses, or synchronization accesses.
It has no idea, it only looks at
the read write accesses coming from an individual
processor and honoring them in the order in
which it appears and making sure that they can
merged across all these processors to preserve the
SC guarantee. So the upshot is that there's
going to be coherence action on every read write
access that the model sees. If this guy writes
to a memory location, then the sequentially
consistent memory model has to ensure that this
write is inserted into this global order
somewhere. In order to insert that in the
global order somewhere, it has to perform
the coherence action with respect to all the
other processors. That's the upshot of not
distinguishing between normal data accesses and synchronization accesses
that is inherent in the SC memory model.